jacques alain bénisti bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec l'eau sur rt
france de nouvelles manifestations donc
aujourd'hui contre la loi sécurité
globale un des rapporteurs de l'onu qui
demande à la france une révision en
profondeur de cette proposition de loi
est selon vous le gouvernement at il
intérêt à faire marche arrière
goûter ce n'est pas une question de
faire marche arrière ou pas c'est de
savoir si ce texte de loi est compatible
avec notre constitution en tant que
présidente de la commission des lois je
pense que effectivement il avait besoin
d'être écrit il a été réécrit et je
pense qu'à mon avis la constitution et
des textes de constitution autour de ce
texte sont normalement au calais et
qu'il n'y aura aucun problème
alors c'est l'article 24 du projet de
loi qui est le plus contesté le chef de
l'état l'a assuré hier lors de son
interview aux journalistes de brut les
journalistes et les citoyens pourront
continuer à filmer et a diffusé des
images de manifestations
l'article a été réécrit par le parlement
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous du coup
aujourd'hui écouter pour l'instant
j'attends véritablement que le parlement
donc vote
désormais ce texte il y va de la
protection véritable de nos policiers
c'est vrai qu'il devait être amendé et
réécrit maintenant qu'il l'a été il peut
être content et donc à l'assemblée
nationale et être doté alors justement
cet équilibre à la fois protection des
policiers avec la liberté de deux filets
en liberté des journalistes et de tous
citoyens de pouvoir filmer ces policiers
pendant les manifestations cet équilibre
il passe par où selon vous écouter
encore une fois je pense qu'on fait des
confusions
c'est pas le fait de filmer ou de ne pas
filmer c'est l'exploitation qui est fait
justement des films sur les policiers on
tient d'intervenir
le texte est extrêmement précis
là-dessus et je dois dire que maintenant
il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas vous ne
pas pouvoir le présenter devant les
députés à l'assemblée nationale
le sénat qui est dominé on le rappelle
par les républicains et l'union
centriste pour adopter l'article 24 sans
le modifier
un vote dit conforme qui empêcherait
alors l'assemblée nationale de le
réécrire rapidement c'est cela le
scénario possible
écoutez je sais que j'ai un certain
nombre d'anciens de mes collègues qui
veulent que on ne bouge pas le texte
simplement le message que j'ai alors
dire c'est que si le texte tel qu'il est
rédigé aujourd'hui n'est pas rectifié il
se peut effectivement que le conseil
d'état et que le conseil constitutionnel
de rejette donc c'est pas vrai ta ble
ment la volonté sinon ça donnerait
raison à tous ceux qui manifestent
aujourd'hui donc je pense que les
dernières réécriture qui ont été opérés
sur ce texte sont à mon avis protectrice
en matière je dirais de diffusion de ces
images et en même temps protège bien sûr
les personnes c'est-à-dire les policiers
alors pendant que le sénat examinera le
projet doit sécurité globale l'assemblée
nationale débattra du projet de loi sur
le séparatisme
or ce texte contient une disposition qui
est similaire à l'article 24 elle crée
un nouveau délit de mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui par diffusion
d'informations relatives à sa vie privée
ou professionnelle
comment est ce que vous envisagez ce
nouveau vote écoutez je pense que
effectivement il y a encore je sais que
le texte va être présentée soit cette
semaine soit la semaine prochaine il y
encore des discussions qui ont lieu je
pense également commission des lois
entre les différents députés des
différentes tendances
mais je pense que c'est un pour
l'instant c'est un bon texte et je pense
qu à mon avis qu'il faudra il faudra pas
le changer alors pour conclure en
quelques mots nouvelle manifestation
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
craignez des violences cet après midi
malheureusement depuis quelques temps
les violences abonde on ne peut plus
maintenant s'exprimer ou vouloir dire
quelque chose sans appliquer des
violences les premiers malheureusement
qui subissent ces violences aujourd'hui
sont évidemment d'abord les policiers
même si tu en entends évidemment il ya
quelques policiers qui extrapole un
petit peu leur leurs possibilités en
intervention et ce sont des cas
extrêmement rare mais ils se font la
plupart du temps dans ce genre de
manifestation taper dessus modeste et
cracher dessus
insulter donc moi je souhaite au
contraire beaucoup de courage à nos
policiers pour maintenir ces différentes
manifestations qui malheureusement sont
reprises par des groupes extrémistes qui
viennent simplement pour casser du flic
merci beaucoup jacques alain bénisti
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes maire les
républicains de villiers sur marne